el apoyo de la Unión Europea Ucrania es
indefinido así lo prometió la presidenta
de la comisión europea Úrsula
vonderleyen en su visita que con abrazos
y sonrisas la emisoria Europea y el
presidente bolo de intercelensky
afianzaron su Unión como bloqueo
occidental contrario a Rusia y sus
aliados
podemos decirles que tienen a su lado a
sus amigos europeos todo el tiempo que
haga falta y que somos amigos para
siempre
con su visita wonderlayen confirmó el
paquete de ayuda de 5000 millones de
euros a Ucrania aprobado este septiembre
e incluso recibió una condecoración por
su apoyo a Ucrania durante la Guerra
Esta es la tercera vez que la
representante de la Unión Europea visita
el país desde el inicio del conflicto
pero la primera desde que kiev se ha
convertido en candidata para pertenecer
al bloque
el proceso de adhesión está bien
encaminado es impresionante ver la
velocidad la determinación y la
precisión con la que están avanzando
algo que Ucrania lleva pidiendo desde
antes de la guerra
Juguemos en camino al Estado de
membresía
estoy seguro de que sucederá y será una
de las victorias más importantes de
nuestro país Yes pero pese al apoyo de
la Unión Europea la posible integración
de Ucrania al bloque es un tema delicado
para ingresar en la organización Ucrania
debería cumplir con requisitos como
garantizar el cumplimiento de Derechos
Humanos tener un estado de derecho pleno
y una democracia funcional además
Moscú y advertido que la membresía de
Ucrania traspasaría una línea roja
factores que complican la adhesión del
país